whoopi goldberg if you see her i did
today which there was a great response
olivia rondu had a great response to
that and she said well well whoopi just
you know
pretty much said that men can't have
children
like that whoopi's banks that men
the view host will be goldberg erupts on
abortion debate how dare men talk about
what a fetus wants
ex-conservative anna navarro on
conservative majority on supreme court
be careful what you wish for
so whoopi goldberg she was making like a
like an anti-trans argument is that what
she was well she was like hands off my
body doc yeah but she's implying that
men can't have children by saying this
right and that's kind of verboten
at least in some context well she's a
she's an old school liberal she doesn't
understand the new cult and what they
believe and everything like that so
so she's all for her body but she's also
a pro vaccine a mandatory vaccine if i
don't want to judge this too much
because i didn't watch the entire thing
i watched like 30 to 40 seconds of it
and she was fired up
this this really this really bugs me too
even even on the surface she said do any
of you men have any eggs or the
possibility of carrying a fetus how dare
you talk about what a fetus wants you
have no idea i'm fine if you disagree
with abortion i have no problem with
that my problem comes when you tell me
what i need to do with my doctor and my
family how dare you how dare you you
know uh i'm i'm pro-choice and it's a
really it's a if you have to really
break it down to like its philosophical
route to understand what i mean by that
because i certainly don't agree with the
left they're pro-abortion it's very very
different things have changed so i can
understand some of the righteous
indignation but men certainly have a
right to an argument in the debate
that's absurd it takes a man and woman
to make a child and it's also
nightmarish when you see stories there
was one video i watched where a guy
is like
following this woman into an abortion
clinic screaming please don't kill my
son please stop please
he drops to his knees and he's crying
out in front of it and she's just like
get away from me and that's that's like
yeah man this is not an easy uh um moral
situation these are these are deeply
philosophical questions and they're
questions that government can't solve
you know i i am pro-life i'm deeply
pro-life um but i understand the
limitations of government fixing this
problem the truth is if you have
somebody that wants to terminate their
baby um
i don't think i don't think they should
have the right to do that because
they're they're they're taking life
that's not peaceful um at the same time
i i recognize that um
you know
compelling someone to carry a child they
don't want
is going to end up poorly that that
situation is going to be bad it's really
tough because i think there's there's so
many uh people's perspective on it are
very very different you know when i was
talking with sheamus uh freedom tunes
his view was very much that the word
abortion means the needless termination
of a pregnancy and my view on it is any
circumstance in which a doctor
terminates the life of of the baby and
so to me that could mean serious mental
health issues i'm sorry not not mental
serious health issues for the mother and
the child and a decision that has to
come from a medical doctor and the woman
and to sheamus the argument was
literally like people using abortion as
contraception or just deciding they
won't don't want to take risks and so i
don't want to uh i'm not trying to um
diminish his total argument because you
know because i was about to go
head-to-head with it and he's not here
right right right that's what i'm saying
right
i don't want to put words in his mouth
because not here to defend himself we we
had a big discussion we disagree like a
miscarriage is a type of abortion so i i
it's actually called an involvement yeah
they call them involuntary abortions
because the fetus is aborted it's
involuntarily
you know not against the word
involuntary is the big part there right
right right so um you know we we talked
about this quite a bit yesterday when we
were discussing roe v wade and um how
the supreme court it seems like they're
leaning towards overturning it or
effectively overturning it with the
ruling on the mississippi uh uh abortion
ban but we here's what we should talk
about like when you overturning roe
versus way doesn't end abortion right it
just means that the federal
that's some states are going to have it
and some are not and that that solution
won't please everyone either
um but it is much more of a
it'll be it'll be more what was intended
from our our government like like if you
look there's no abortion is not a
constitutional issue if we if we say
that we live under the u.s constitution
there's nothing in there that suggests
that the federal government should be
making these decisions yeah i think
clarence thomas was asking like where in
the constitution does it say this is a
right or something that effect and the
woman argument was i think her name was
wrinkleman uh and she's the solicitor
general and she said and the 14th
amendment and he's like i can read the
second amendment
and see what it says like what are you
referring to right and he made a really
good point it is to me an insane
argument that it's a constitutional
right to get an abortion that that she
said it's it's it's it's seated in life
life liberty in the pursuit of happiness
or something that it's a liberty
argument
and i'm like you know my view is
there's a very serious challenge in what
the government should be allowed to do
when it comes to
you know people's medical decisions and
their bodies and the issue with abortion
that i think the left
willfully ignores is that the ch the
baby is a life the mother is a life
they're both valid it's it's annoying to
me when i see there's like a meme going
around from these leftists and they're
like
it's actually someone i know posted this
saying the argument about whether or not
a fetus is a life is the wrong argument
the real argument is whether a woman is
a life and i'm like that what are you
even you're not even saying anything
look i get it women are alive and the
babies are alive we're trying to figure
out how to do this right you're not
helping by making these nonsensical
statements that's a bad argument even i
think most people that are pro-abortion
would admit that's a bad argument now
they're posting these memes i'm just
like look man
it's really scary to me the idea that
the government is given precedent for
being involved in medical decisions and
and i'm like
that's the challenge of abortion is that
the the to a certain for a certain
amount of time the fetus is dependent
upon the mother and now you've got
government intervention in america i
don't like it i don't like vaccine
passports i don't like vaccine mandates
i don't like any kind of mandate you
know what i mean for medical choices
that shouldn't be something the
government's involved in and so that's a
very rudimentary thing i see
and then i see what ends what you get
when the left actually wins there
here's what happens the left comes in
and says see shouldn't we have
pro-choice and then someone like me goes
yeah and they go great hey everybody you
can use abortion as contraception now
and i'm like no what no and then that's
what they end up doing and so then it's
just there's no middle like to me it's
still so philosophical and there's no
you know like it's just clearly wrong to
me but again it gets messy trying to
have laws to fix these things right one
of my first stories ever as a newspaper
reporter years ago as a cub reporter at
the panama city news herald in florida
and a
young woman probably less than 25 years
old
um was she she murdered her baby and
that that was just just born i think
it's been a long many years but she just
left it i think she might have drowned
in the bathroom or something and i and i
covered that did a couple of stories on
it um
she as far as i remember i think she
went to prison for life for like a
really long time
um but if she would have done it a week
earlier i remember thinking about a week
earlier it's perfectly legal that's
right um and and so like you can't you
know
trying to have government have solutions
to this um you know like it it gets
messy but um as an individual i just say
like no it's it's life and and the one
thing the government is supposed to do
is protect life so well here's where i
think look we uh i'll go back to what
we're talking about with civil war stuff
and you were saying that you know you
don't think it'll be that bad i actually
i think that i don't the right way to
describe this i completely disagree
we have seen non-stop escalation and no
sign of it slowing down
if i were to ask you in 2014
do you think that in 2020 a thousand
right-wing individuals would storm into
the capital interrupting the electoral
college proceedings resulting in 10
months of solitary confinement and the
expansion of the capital police
nationwide you'd be like shut up
if i said in in you know in a few years
there's going to be roving bands of
far-left extremists burning down
buildings and killing people and a guy's
gonna get shot in the chest and murdered
you would tell me to shut up and i know
this because this is literally what
happened when i said it was gonna happen
back in 2017 2018 when i was covering
the the street violence i was talking to
people pundits politicos libertarians dc
types and i was saying like guys i see
this getting worse it's only getting
worse and they were like oh shut up the
state would never allow this to escalate
beyond the proud boys and antifa no
one's gonna die they're larpers and then
sure enough dude walks up to aaron
nelson and just puts two in his chest
for no reason and we we we've seen
consistently escalating violence to the
point where
even after january 6 i don't think it
was an insurrection i think it was a
riot i think it was bad some of these
people the doors were open they were
letting still really bad
i still have people walk up and be like
do you think it's going to be a civil
war and now what happens i say january 6
and they go
oh yeah so you think about january 6 not
as insane as the democrats think it is
but hey from their perspective troubling
they deeply trust if these people want
to come out and simultaneously criticize
me for saying i think a civil war is a
strong potential but then also claim
they want to criticize me for saying
that but then also claimed january 6 was
an insurrection i'm like what was wrong
about what i said then if you agree with
if you believe that now what happens
come june 2022 if we get another major
culture war catalyst
there's no sign of this slowing down for
any reason right now it's winter winter
things you know are chill this happened
last year people were like ah it's cold
out we're not going to see riots and
then january 6th happened so what
happens come springtime especially june
2022 they overturned roe v wade man you
are going to see riots and it's going to
escalate and now with kyle rittenhouse
and the self-defense precedents and a
lot of things we've seen the left is
arguing that they need to bring their
guns out
they need to bring their guns out
because the right's going to bring their
guns out we've already had we had two
shootouts in portland i think only a
couple months ago it's the craziest
thing to me that people are like nah i
think things are chilling out i'm like
dude it's been a month of winter and
that's why you're saying that a couple
months ago we had someone on the show
and i was like we had two shootouts in
portland literally left and right-wing
groups shooting at each other in the
street we had a guy driving his truck
and antifa blockaded the street and
aimed rifles at the guy in his truck and
he pulled out his gun and pointed it at
them and i'm like
why would i believe this is slowing down
now we got a midterm year and they're
saying the republicans republicans are
going to sweep yo we already had people
burn down buildings across this country
killing 25.
why would it get any
better no it's a good question and i i
don't want to minimize
the violence that that we're
experiencing or that we saw you know on
january 6th or or before that which in
my opinion like like you know you find
yourself january 6 with bad what we saw
before that was much worse to me it was
much more because the difference was i
look at dc they're they got cops
everywhere now again like like they
weren't there that day like things were
things were bad but i look at shop
owners that were everything that they've
built is being destroyed nobody was
looking after them we had as you said 25
people died it was it was the bloodiest
civil unrest that we've had since the
60s so so i don't minimize that but
these people then went and voted for joe
biden which which people in these big
cities they went blue they went hard
blue yeah these people
kamala harris who was soliciting
donations to bail the rioters out joe
biden 13 of his staff members helped
bail the rioters out and the people in
minnesota said
blue no matter who yeah
people would actually say that blue no
matter who i'm like what is going on
think about what you're doing before you
do it so it was it was incredibly
dangerous like like that i remember
being infuriated by that like like
here's the thing you know written house
got gofundme shut down
it's one guy accused of a crime you
actually know the details
when you when you're just giving money
to a bunch of people that have been
arrested for all this violent crime that
to me i found it really troubling thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you